-The White House has been rocked
yet again my anonymous warnings
about the President's
fitness for office,
and yet Republicans
are still moving forward
with his Supreme Court pick.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Trump is being allowed
to fill a lifetime seat
to the nation's highest court
despite constant leaks
about how dangerous
and erratic he is.
Every day, new details emerge
from famed journalist
Bob Woodward's
upcoming book "Fear,"
whose cover looks like
a lifetime movie poster
about an evil stepfather.
[ Laughter ]
And those details
confirm that Trump
is as vulgar and petulant
in private as he is in public.
In the book,
even his own aides
describe Trump
as an "unhinged idiot"
and "professional liar"
who "acted like,
and had the understanding
of, a fifth- or sixth-grader."
[ Laughter ]
Of course, you don't need
a book to know that.
You just need eyeballs
and ear holes.
Trump is in private exactly
who he seems to be in public.
It's both shocking and not
surprising at the same time.
I mean,
the guy literally misspelled
his own wife's name in a tweet.
[ Laughter ]
Not like he's doing that
in public, and then, in private,
besting world leaders
in games of chess.
"Bad news, Angela.
It seems you've failed
to counteract my queen's gambit
by taking my pawn.
And now my knight
has your king in check.
So, if you'll excuse me,
I have to meet my wife...
Melanoma?"
[ Laughter ]
Now, one of the most
eye-catching allegations
in the book
is that Trump's closest aides
have resorted
to hiding documents from him
to stop him
from signing or reading them.
-Woodward describes
an administrative coup d'etat
and a nervous breakdown
of the executive branch,
with senior aides conspiring
to pluck official papers
from the President's desk so he
couldn't see or even sign them.
-Woodward also details
the actions of some top aides
in the White House, including
former economic adviser,
Goldman Sachs veteran
Gary Cohn.
"According to Woodward,
Cohn 'stole a letter
off Trump's desk'
that the President
was intending to go sign
to formally withdraw the U.S.
from a trade agreement
with South Korea."
-Porter consulted Cohn --
Gary Cohn -- who told him,
according to Woodward,
"I can stop this.
I'll just take the paper
off his desk."
-Craziest thing about
that story is that
if you steal a piece of paper
from Trump's desk,
he won't even know it's gone.
He's like a guy who's blown away
by the first half
of a magic trick.
"Oh, my God! How did you get
that lady inside the box?!"
[ Laughter ]
This isn't even the first time
there's been
an explosive allegations
from a tell-all book about how
the Trump White House
deals with paper.
You might remember that,
just a few weeks ago,
former Trump aide
Omarosa Manigault Newman
wrote in her book
that she once saw Trump
eat paper in the Oval Office.
[ Laughter ]
Now, in fairness,
maybe he was just eating it
so Gary Cohn
couldn't steal it first.
[ Laughter ]
Gary comes in late at night,
looking for it,
and then,
Trump flips on a light and says,
"Oh, are you looking
for your paper, Gary?"
[ Laughter ]
"Because I'm afraid I put it
somewhere safe -- my belly."
[ Laughter ]
"Now, if you'll excuse me,
I have to meet my wife...
Mallorca?"
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
But the book...
The book is also filled
with stories from Trump aides
who have loyally served him and
agreed with most of his agenda,
trying to cast themselves
as heroic saviors
protecting the public
from the whims of a madman.
For example,
Cohn threatened to resign
after Trump's comments
on Charlottesville.
But Trump "persuaded his
economic adviser to stay on."
Man, I would've loved
to see that conversation.
"I'm gonna shove this
resignation letter up your ass."
"Oh, yeah? Well, I'm gonna
shove it in my mouth,
and it'll end up
in the same place."
[ Laughter ]
Second, it's easy to talk tough,
but unless you're actually
willing to resign
and tell the American people
everything you know,
then your tough talk
is worthless.
John Kelly's like a kid
who tells his friends
he's gonna stand up to the bully
who steals his lunch money,
and then, when lunchtime comes,
tells the bully,
"Keep shaking!
There's more in my back pocket!"
[ Laughter ]
Now, Trump has denied
all of this,
and yesterday
in the Oval Office,
he called Woodward's book
"a work of fiction,"
but that's not what
he told Woodward on the phone
when he called him
just a few weeks ago
to complain that he hadn't been
interviewed for the book.
Woodward recorded the call,
and Trump
was very complimentary.
Oh, my God. How is there
always a secret tape
that contradicts
everything Trump says?
[ Laughter ]
Although I guess
I shouldn't be surprised
the same guy
who can be tricked into
not signing a piece of paper
doesn't realize
everyone around him
has a GoPro
strapped to their heads.
[ Laughter ]
But, hey,
in fairness to Trump
he probably didn't know
he was being recorded.
-Oh, my God.
He's like a --
[ Applause ]
He's like a bank robber who
waves at the security camera.
[ Laughter ]
Craziest part of this phone call
is when Trump explains
that his aides never asked him
if he wanted to do
an interview with Woodward
because they were too afraid.
-So to recap,
Trump says Bob Woodward's book
is a work of fiction because
he never spoke to Woodward
because his aides
were too afraid to talk to him
about doing an interview
for Woodward's book,
which is literally
called "Fear."
[ Laughter ]
Trump is such a bad liar,
even his lies
prove that he's lying.
"Your book called 'Fear'
is totally inaccurate,
and I would've told you that
if my aides weren't too afraid
to come talk to me.
Now, if you'll excuse me,
I have to meet my wife,
Mesothelioma."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"That's it.
I got to write that down.
That's definitely it."
For almost two years, we've had
this frustrating spectacle
of Trump's closest aides
anonymously warning us
that the president they work for
is erratic and dangerous
but refusing to actually
do anything about it,
and yesterday, we got the most
stunning example of that yet
from an anonymous op-ed
in "The New York Times," titled
"I Am Part of the Resistance
Inside the Trump
Administration,"
Warning about Trump's erratic
and reckless behavior.
And now the op-ed
has put Trump supporters
in the weird position
of having to defend
the President's mental health,
like South Carolina Senator
Lindsey Graham,
who said this Wednesday on CNN.
-To those who believe
that this man is a fool,
that this man is crazy,
that there's something wrong
with Donald Trump
and it's just the people around
him that keep us safe,
you don't know
what you're talking about.
-Yeah, if you're out there
saying Trump's a kook
or he's crazy
or he's unfit for office,
you don't know
what you're talking about.
-I think he's a kook.
I think he's crazy.
I think he's unfit for office.
-Oh, my God!
The author of the op-ed
was Lindsey Graham!
That would explain the paragraph
where he calls Trump
crazier than a wet mule eating
corn through a picket fence.
[ Laughter ]
But this week has been
a perfect distillation
of the GOP's complicity
in the Trump debacle,
because even as a parade
of Trump officials
quietly warn the public
that he's unfit for office,
they're letting him hang around
to fill a lifetime seat
on the Supreme Court
with his handpicked nominee
Brett Kavanaugh.
And in his
confirmation hearing so far,
Kavanaugh has been exactly
the kind of loyal partisan
Trump would want.
For example, he's been asked
a series of questions
that could be crucial
to the Russia investigation,
like "Can the president
pardon himself?"
"Does he have to comply
with a subpoena?"
And every time,
he has refused to answer
even those basic questions.
-President Trump claims
he has an absolute right
to pardon himself.
Does he?
-The question of self-pardons is
something I've never analyzed.
-Can a sitting President
be required to respond
to a subpoena?
-So that's
a hypothetical question.
-No, it's not.
The president's lawyer,
Rudy Giuliani,
is on TV every day
talking about how Trump
would just ignore a subpoena.
You know, this guy.
Always looked like
he just had a resignation letter
shoved up his ass.
I mean, it's mind-boggling
that we're even considering
allowing the President
to fill a lifetime seat
on the Supreme Court
while his own aides
warn the public
that he's unfit for office.
But that's the corrupt bargain
the GOP has made.
They're not heroes
containing Trump.
They're collaborators
working with him
even though they know he's...
-A kook.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]